hey guys it's max today i'm comparing
the brand new apple watch se
against the apple watch series 3. if
you're looking for a budget apple watch
it is quite a difficult choice choosing
which one you should buy and if the se
is worth the extra money
so today we're gonna be comparing
everything from the design of the
watches
the features the sensors the displays
different capacities we're gonna cover
everything and if you watch through the
whole video by the end of it
we're gonna make this decision very easy
for you let's start out with colors i
have
a space gray series 3 right here you can
also get it in a silver just like my se
so those are the only options you have
whereas with se there is also a gold
option of course you can also customize
your watch with the
bands and the brand new se does have the
ability to use any of the bands
including the new ones like this braided
solo loop which i
absolutely love you can still attach it
to the series 3 but it's not going to
fit correctly you're going to have some
silver sticking out on the sides because
it's not designed for and that's because
the actual cases are
different now these watches here with
the series 3 i have a 38 millimeter
and the se is a 40. so a couple things
changed one of them
is the exterior of the chassis so the se
slightly larger
with that said though the series three
even though it's smaller it's actually
thicker and it's heavier
the crown has been redesigned it has a
little bit more grip because the cutouts
are larger
it's actually at the same time slimmer
as well and the biggest difference is it
also has
haptic feedback so as i'm scrolling here
i'm getting a little
uh pulse telling me that i'm scrolling
it's not a huge
deal but it definitely is a nice extra
touch right below that we have the
side button on the apple watch series 3
it sticks out over here and it's not
flush with the body
doesn't look as nice and clean as the se
and newer watches
where it is flush you probably notice
that the microphone is right between the
crown and the button on the new se
whereas the series 3 it was on the other
side next to the speakers now
along with the difference in placement
which helps the watch hear you better
the quality of the microphone has been
improved and it also enables you to have
the noise app over here which in the
background it will actually listen to
noises it'll tell you if you're in a
loud environment or you can use it by
itself
which we use all the time here at max
tech because the mic was moved there is
extra space for a larger speaker on the
se
and it's about 50 louder which is great
if you're speaking to siri
if you're getting notifications or a
phone call i took off the watch draft so
let's flip these over and take a look at
the sensors
the series 3 has a lot more aluminum and
it's using
a composite sensor this little circle
here so basically plastic
where on the se we have glass all around
here it's actually
ceramic and sapphire crystal now design
looks different the series 3
has two lights and two sensors where the
se has one
more powerful light in the center a lot
of sensors around the outside so those
have been updated and we have the second
generation
heart rate sensors here along with that
the accelerometer has been updated it
could sense twice the g-forces now
and you also get fall detection so if
that's important to you
you won't get that with the series 3.
the series 3 also misses out
on the compass and the always-on
altimeter which are great features for
hikers
now another difference is that the
series 3 cannot be purchased with
lte whereas the se can as you guys see
right here i do have the lte
version of the se now the series 3 was
actually the first apple watch to have
the lte option but then apple dropped it
later
when they had newer watches and the se
also stands out because it is the first
apple watch where it only costs you
fifty dollars more to go for the lte
option um instead of a hundred dollars
like on all of the other apple watches
now that is because apple really wants
to push this apple watch
to maybe teenagers kids older adults
people that don't have phones with their
new family setup option which we showed
you guys how to use you guys can check
out the link in the video description
and i went for it just because this is
gonna be for my kid so it's definitely a
great choice if you want lte
and now let's compare the displays where
we have some massive
differences in both how it looks and the
capabilities
so the first thing that will pop up to
you is how much larger display is on the
se
it's technically about 35 larger now
with that comes a difference in the
glass here
we have more squared off but rounded
edges here this is a perfectly round
bezel just like on the new ipads or
iphones
and the display on the inside has
rounded corners as well
instead of just a regular you know
square or rectangular shape
now with that large display you guys can
see in the maps app how much more
is visible here i have them both
centered the same
on the se i can see the hospital right
here i see indiana i see these side
streets
so you get much more information at a
glance and it's easier more pleasant to
look at if you're using maps
along with that if you want to do stuff
such as photos let me go ahead and open
up
the photos app here this really shows
off the difference in the displays where
it's filling up the whole frame
the se is definitely nicer here's what
that difference looks like in the real
world
with an apple watch face this is the
fire one with the se
it's filling up the whole display it
looks much nicer
along with that the se has much more
watch faces it actually has 15 more
options
and it has all of the watch faces from
the series 6 and the
latest updates whereas the series 3 is
really limited because of its display
so a lot of these nicer full screen
watch faces
like the california one that i like and
these ones that just fill up give you a
lot of info they're just
simply not available on the series 3.
and now
let's talk about performance the se is
using the s5 chip and it has twice the
performance of the
s3 chip inside the series 3. now that's
going to make
everything smoother apps might launch a
little bit faster and what i noticed is
for the initial setup
it is quite a bit quicker on the se
that's probably because it also has a w3
wireless chip which supports bluetooth 5
as well
so you have more performance maybe a
little bit more energy efficiency with
the newer chips
and a smoother overall experience
because of that w3 chip having bluetooth
5 if you're going to pair some bluetooth
headphones to your apple watch and
listen to podcasts or music
you're going to get a lot larger range
of signal or better reliability in
general
compared to the series three now if you
do want to store things on your apple
watch the se
actually has four times more storage you
have 32 gigabytes
compared to eight gigabytes you also
have to remember that
you have to have the watchua software on
here which leaves you with more around
five
five and a half gigs on the series three
with that both of them have the same
wi-fi they have the same water
resistance and they're rated the same 18
hours of battery life
just like apple rates all of their apple
watches now if the se
has the same battery from the series 4
which that we haven't seen the teardown
yet
but if so you should get a little bit
better battery life
in the real world when i upgraded from
my series 3 to the series 4
i did notice an increase of battery life
at the end of the day i would have about
30 35 remaining when i put on the
charger compared to being close to dead
so with all of that said
let's wrap this up and answer the
original question
which apple watch should you get the se
or the series three and i'll let you
guys know that i'm gonna make it easy
for you guys
at 279 dollars with a 50 lte
option the se is an amazing
value and i believe that for almost
everybody out there
that's wanting to buy an apple watch you
should go with
the se not only because you get extra
performance you get some better battery
life a much much nicer display
a lot more storage but because most
people that buy an apple watch they keep
it for two
three even four years even myself if i
wasn't making these videos
um i would keep it for much longer not
be upgrading all the time so this watch
is gonna perform great
and it's gonna get the latest updates
it's to last you a long time
now it gets a little bit more difficult
when you look at the price on amazon
right now
and we'll leave a link down in the video
description you can buy a series 3 for
169
that's 110 less than the s
e it's a really big price difference so
if you're somebody that literally
just wants to do simple fitness tracking
then you want to get notifications on
your wrist
from some apps some texts then the crc
is going to do a
perfectly fine job it still works great
a lot of people are buying him
but if you're somebody that wants to do
anything more than that
you should definitely spend the extra
money on the se
thank you guys for watching let me know
which one you would buy down in the
comment section below
and if you enjoyed the video hit that
like button and consider subscribing
with that circle
above also check out the family setup
option if you're interested in that
video
or if you're considering getting
possibly a series six and if
you want to know if that's worth extra
money we have that video right over
there
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video